change wives he ought to be dr. lives
change organizations guy vs organization
might change the world
so we've all received free advice in our
lives perhaps not from drew it doesn't
give advice but certainly from other
people and if there was a top 10 list of
advice most given this one would
certainly be up there do what makes you
happy it's short it's simple its
intuitive it every time someone tells
you to do what makes you happy does it
really help you decide what to do I'm
here today to tell you that doing what
makes you happy is not the most
practical path to happiness I will show
why this piece of advice while intuitive
doesn't often work and I'll provide an
alternative the avoidance of regret
together with five key mindsets required
to help you get the practice of regret
avoidance right let's see why can't we
do what makes us happy so imagine you're
a student here the Stanford Graduate
School pissed you're thinking about
hostesses so you have three options work
in consulting you work at a big firm or
you found this funny so let's visualize
how happy you would be if you chose any
one of these three options us points
from zero to 10 let's call them
happiness ones let's say consulting
gives you five the big firm gives you
eight and the startup gives you 10 now
if your decision was this simple you
would have no problem you'd say hey I'll
do what makes me happy I'll found a
start-up bad by 10 points but life's not
that simple you see the 1 by 3 matrix
you saw here assumes certainty it
appears no matter what you do it's
always 5 8 and 10 5 8 and 10 but in real
life how happy we are often depends
uncertain future events so let's expand
this 1 by 3 matrix into three by three
matrix your column still signify the
choices that you have but this time your
rows signify scenarios a B and C these
scenarios don't percent just what answer
key but a mix and confluence of
different uncertainties the job market
venture funding love competition and
many more so if you look at this and you
try again to do what makes its most
happy we just can't do it because the
option that makes us the most happy is
different in each scenario its start in
scenario a we're in different in
scenario b and c RC oh it's consulting
what do we do now the good news is this
is not the first time you've faced
problems like this in fact we've faced
problems like this very often in
business and there's one area in
particular where we can adopt some tools
it's called decision theory so the first
approach the decision theory gives us is
called the optimists approach we assume
the best case scenario and pick the
option that makes us most happy in that
scenario in this case the best case
scenario is a we'd found a start-up
approach number two is called the
pessimists approach what we do is we
assume the worst case scenario and again
pick the option that makes is happiest
in that scenario we'd go for consulting
I call these two options they do what
makes you happy approaches because in
both of these approaches what you're
trying to do is we're trying to maximize
your happiness points but the problem is
rarely are we ever very pessimistic or
very optimistic we're not comfortable
assuming everything will go right and
we're not comfortable assuming
everything will go wrong we need a third
approach and decision theory does give
us their approach it's called regret
avoidance so the key to regret avoidance
is not to maximize your happiness but to
minimize your regret what that means is
you try to imagine how sad you would be
if the if the decision that you made
didn't turn out to be the best one
for example in this case if you pick
consulting and scenario a turned out to
be the case you would get five happiness
points but we would have been happier if
you found this daughter in fact it would
be five points out here if you pick the
big firm will be two points out here if
you click the start up and if you work
with a start-up then you will face no
regret we do that for the rest of these
and then what we think about then is how
much exposure to regret are we getting
from each of these three options it's
five two and three the maximum exposure
and then we picked the option that gives
us the list so that is the best case
scenario or the best option if you
minimize are we good so why can't we do
what makes us happy we can't do it
because doing what makes us happy often
requires us to make big assumptions
we're either very optimistic or very
pessimistic regret avoidance doesn't
require either of those making it a more
rational and practical approach so
regret avoidance is an approach
like other approaches there are ways to
do this right and there are ways to do
this wrong and my experience has spanned
the whole gamut so I'd like to share
with you five mindsets that I've learned
help me minimize regret in the best
possible way these are defaults words
action give it your best shot focus and
commit deadlines are your friend and
don't look back let's start with the
first mind set default towards action so
if you turn to the person sitting beside
you and he asked him what do you regret
most in your life they'll likely tell
you about something they did not do
maybe they didn't take the course that
you wanted to take in college maybe they
didn't pursue a romantic relationship
and wonder you know where could that
have taken me maybe they didn't spend
enough time with friends and family and
worry that it's too late when professors
gila vich and medival of Cornell
University asked 1,700 people that same
question they discovered something
interesting they discovered that while
in the short-term people sometimes
regret what they do in the long term the
only really regret what they fail to do
so default towards action because in the
long term you mostly regret what you
don't do even if we default towards
action though sometimes we can still
fail due to self-sabotage this leads us
to mindset number to give it your best
shot the one thing I personally regret
the most in my life is my failure to
give my wife Jane the thoughtful and
heartfelt proposal that she deserves see
I default its words action I proposed
but I kind of just said it there were
things that I said that I wish I didn't
say and there were things that I didn't
say that I wish I did say I was so
afraid of sort of doing it the wrong way
that I suddenly convinced myself that if
I didn't try I wouldn't be disappointed
and I was right I wasn't disappointed
something worse happened I was left with
a deep and long lasting feeling regret
see there's a difference between the
feelings of regret and disappointment
both are emotions that you're faced with
when we have a goal and we don't achieve
our goal but we're faced with this
appointment when circumstances caused us
to fail and we're faced with regret when
our own actions are to blame social
psychologists Marcel's Ellenberg as
showing that feelings of regret our
company by higher levels of guilt and
shame than our feelings of
disappointment in other words compared
to regret this appointment may just feel
like success give it your best shot so
what happens when we combine always
giving things your best shot and always
defaulting to arts action something
we're all very familiar with nice
formula for over commitment so mindset
number three focus in committee well I
always thought that the more options I
had the happier I would be do you
remember the first time you logged on to
the gsbs career job board I remember I
was like super excited so I went through
every job post one by one line by line
you could say it was a equal opportunity
employer
I didn't discriminate companies based on
their location the function there's
industry I just considered them all you
see growing up I didn't have a lot of
options so I always thought you know the
more the merrier as it turns out the
more you the more is not necessarily the
merrier you see the more choices we have
the more we have to say no to the more
choices we have the more doors and have
to close the more choices we have the
more opportunities we feel we have to
let go of there's a researcher called
professor Schwartz in Swarthmore College
in his colleagues they showed that
people who are maximizers people who
like to hoard a lot of options in search
of that one perfect one feel a lot more
regrets than satisfies people who pick
one and just move on focus and come in
whenever a friend tells me to focus on
commit here's our how I react I say you
know what you're right completely right
I'll focus in come in I'll do it okay do
it next month mindset number for
deadlines are your friend so when that
friend comes back to me and you know one
month later and says so how is you how
are you going with your decision to
focus and commit here's what I say in
reply you won't believe what's happened
since one month ago I mean things have
changed your information is available I
need time to think and calibrate can I
get back to you next month so two facts
of life fact number one the more
information we have the better decisions
we can make fact number two the more
time we have the more information we can
gather so what happens when we have
decisions for which there is no deadline
we take that decision to our grave delay
in one day at the time we tend to see
decisions as a good deadlines as the
worst thing since sort of taxes but the
truth as deadlines are our friend
because deadlines protect us from what
Marcel Sundberg calls decision of
version our unwillingness to take
ownership of
sessions that we have to make the longer
we delay making a decision the more we
expect the more experienced regret so
we've defaulted towards action we've
given things our best shot we are
focused we're committed and we're using
deadlines to help us what else could
there be left my cell number five don't
look back at the very core of regret is
comparison a comparison between what is
and what could have been what has been
achieved and what could have been
achieved very often we gain nothing by
looking back in comparing results but we
do it nonetheless I'm sure many in this
room are investors in the stock market
I'm sure many are long-term investors
people who are aiming not for the quick
buck but for long and steady gains over
time in spite of being long-term
investors though we check market price
more often than we need to to what end
when prices are good we do nothing when
things are down well we just feel bad
we're long-term investors not only in
companies but also in our own lives we
should be in it not to make the best
possible decisions they in and day out
but to make the best possible decisions
on average over a long and fulfilling
life time we can't regret what we don't
know and we can't know unless we look
back don't look back
so if there was a top 10 list of advice
most given this would certainly be one
of them do what makes you happy it's
short it's simple it's intuitive if the
problem you're facing is equally short
simple intuitive go right ahead follow
that advice but in the many cases where
your problem is not a simple not as
straightforward you may just want to
avoid regret instead as long as you
default towards action you give things
your best shot you focus and commit you
set deadlines and you don't look back
chances are you'll be happier in the end
thank
you